tu as avec une série que j'adore ça va
c'est 10%
pourtant les audiences fils course en
relais cette semaine à 3 millions de
téléspectateurs le lancement la semaine
dernière à 3 millions 8 ça reste un
succès puisque la france 2 reste leader
avec 7 alors 10% pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas le principe c'est une
série qui concernait d'agents de cinéma
alors il ya plein de références
évidemment il ya un casting de rêve
il ya beaucoup de guest dj yahia que
charlotte gainsbourg qui l'a fait face à
la montée écoutez rigoler quand même par
le talent est grand palais c'est mon
avis c'est gianni camou quémande où
c'est alors moi c'est une tactique et
que j'aime beaucoup et qui manque est
assez réaliste quand on connaît la
chance de peut être un pixel ce monde là
et alors il dit que c'est une saison
supplémentaire
oui ou non pour l'instant c'est pas trop
mais je pense à soultz il meurt jamais
je pense pas sa patrie marié un petit
peu à bout de cette saison
personnellement la montagne
téléspectateurs je suis méga fan de
cette série mais cette saison je me fait
un peu chier à mon expression autres
tournent autour de la vie privée des
personnages et franchement c'est pas ce
que je cherche c'est son champ ils ont
changé les scénaristes en fait tu
regardes orange et ses bons juges et
regardons analysons nous sommes une
émission média et décrit soyons un peu
sérieux extrait avec josé garcia s'il
vous plaît quand vous mettez la baisse
quand vous serrez le tablier vous donner
un tout et un tout c'est une brigade
élus brigade c'est une famille est là
maintenant
là j'ai besoin de ma famille parce que
ce restaurant c'est toute ma vie
ok alors si on n'arrive pas surprendre
les gens si on n'arrive pas à aaa à les
rendre heureux
alors là un s'est terminé alors quand on
est la toge la toque la toque pardon
canton
la toque canton quand on sert la brigade
et là on devient quoi le tablier merde
c'est mon récent quoi il allait s'y quoi
allez-y donc essayer de voilà c'est ma
vie et la vie ok coupet s'est coupé et
on va enchaîner avec un autre expert
mais il ya le fait que ça avec muriel
robin est sans équivalent déjà quand on
voit là où il y avait plus qu'assez
c'est quand même la classe regardez vous
enverriez sur invite quand votre
connaissance pareillement voit la mairie
est en train de nous expliquer à quel
point le métier d'humoriste était
compliquée voire déprimant
ah bon pas du tout ne pas du tout donc
je disais simplement que voilà je moi je
ne fais pas de coaching en donc ça c'est
trop dommage parce que franchement pour
moi vous êtes la meilleure je me suis
même dit peut-être que je pouvais vous
coachez aussi mais oui ce que je vois
que vous jouez de plus en plus de rôles
dramatiques et c'est très bien mais sur
les larmes je trouve que parfois c'est
pas même sur la voie je dirais les petit
trémolo tout ça je peux peut-être vous
donner un ou deux trucs mais échange de
bons procédés mais je me débrouille tout
seul et c'est vrai qu'il ya un regard
vraiment incroyable sur les comédiens y
avait notamment mis ma ti cul à qui ont
expliqué que bon le côté que des séries
et c'était cca c'est assez judicieux et
surtout quel justement que le cinéma
snob un peu la télé là wim wenders a
donc la cemac sur sa wii ça c'est
réaliste
alors petit bémol car il en faut
apparemment pour faire une suite
il semblerait que les acteurs soient de
plus en plus gourmand est vrai ou pas ce
qu'ils servent aussi rondement chanson
loire du paf comme on dit dans les
couloirs dans les données colligées par
les coulisses va laisser un peu plus sa
marge brute demande d'argent ait oud
tout laisser normalement voyez ce que je
veux dire les jeunes ils sont de
l'argent ils veulent pas après leur
distribuer moi je suis à chenommet
arrête geste
ses fans de cette série parce qu on a
cité comme comme ça quelques guest à la
volée chaque épisode chaque geste et je
sais pas si j'ai le droit de le dévoiler
vous savez qui est le dernier geste de
cette c'est cette ultime saison à l'as
est dévoilée on verra bien sigourney
weaver oui parce que les américains sont
fans de cette série qui rentrait dans le
catalogue de netflix
ah bah ouais mon rappelle comme elle un
gros paquet d'oseille peuvent pas
redistribuer la saison d'après aux
autres donc ça devient un petit peu les
américains sont fans vous aimez venir
vous ben oui il est fan de divine a
raison ça s'appelle coleman agent sur
netflix jennifer aniston en l'occurrence
est alors besnehard a dit parce qu'on a
dit que c'était l'ultime saison que non
que c'était la fin d'un cycle mais qu'un
nouveau cycle aller reprendre
il a dit ça dans les colonnes de voici
et de la bonne ligue 1 lille a il a
aussi révélé qu'ils avaient refusé de
participer à la série en l'occurrence
catherine deneuve cause et sophie
marceau qui est pourtant sa grande amie
façon c'est génial oui oui là on a de
l'info j'aime bien ça bravo bravo si ça
rattrape l'euro tout à l'heure